they came in search of a better life in
a magical new world they endured a
dangerous sea voyage and braved a
hostile environment to establish
England's first permanent foothold in a
strange land called America and then
they vanished without a trace there's no
time 13 o clock
[Music]
and it's episode 98 yeah 98 this is
gonna be a good one consistence mostly
gonna be about the Lost Colony of
Roanoke well yeah we figured okay we are
recording this on July 1st which is
actually Tom's birthday know what thank
you
49 years old oldest [ __ ] some 80 year
olds like yeah 49 young whippersnapper
yeah I got I got you a carrot cake and
yeah
oh you haven't get some of that later
yeah but yeah but since this show is
going up the day before the fourth of
July or Independence Day if you're an
American yeah we decided to do kind of a
American themed show like American
mystery show so we wanted I've been
wanting to do the Lost Colony of Roanoke
for a long time because this is
something that it's a case that always
kind of fascinated me before I was a kid
like I said it's it's something that
obviously had a pretty mundane I mean
obviously something happened those
people was like supernatural or that but
the fact that we don't know exactly well
after all was exactly what happened to
them exactly where they went and we
never will yeah probably not and just
kind of the creepy clues left behind and
stuff like that so it always kind of
fascinated me for I was a kid so I would
want to do this for a while I thought
well it's kind of American themed
because it's like America's oldest cold
case I guess yeah oldest missing persons
case I was first introduced to it when I
was a little kid watching regular
broadcast television in search of
Leonard Nimoy and his voice over to the
Roanoke case made this just seems so
creepy especially back in the day when
you were a little kid you know I don't
know I spent a long time since I've seen
that in search of episode that's
probably nothing like I remember but I
remember it just being really creepy and
hot and ominous then maybe some bad
happen to these people yeah yeah which I
don't know if it did or not I think I
have a good idea I think I have a good
idea what probably happened to them it's
funny because I think I saw the same in
search of episode that you're talking
about yeah but it's funny because you
know what I always think of what I think
of this case is I always
think of the Harlan Ellison short story
which was called Croatoan and it was
kind of it wasn't really based on this
exactly but it was kind of like it was
almost like a more modern like
metaphorical kind of telling of it but
that could that was the detail that
always like creeped me out that there
that you kind of arrived and there's
nobody there and then there's like this
little clue left you're not really sure
this message right right and so that
that aspect of it always kind of creeps
me out yeah so I didn't want to do this
for a long time and I thought well you
know since this is going up before
Independence Day we'll do like an
America mystery didn't take the thing
yeah and I bet maybe some of our British
listeners and maybe our Indian listeners
and maybe even our Australian listeners
have never heard of the Lost Colony of
Roanoke it's a kind of an American
mystery you know there's a lot of
different American colonies or British
colonies and Dutch colonies there
anything think there may have been a
German one set up on the eastern coast
of the Americas yeah they ended up being
within the United States later on but
there was no United States at that time
some of those many of those colonies
just disappear that is vanished one of
them was Roanoke and this was the over
this one it was the first one what
happened yeah if we had known what
happened to them it would have been the
oldest settlement yeah in what became
the United States yeah so coos were left
behind and because it didn't sound as
the oldest right it's a pretty weird
story yeah it is a pretty creepy story
and like there's a lot of theories about
what happened to the people some of them
much crazier than others but you know
we'll get into that a little bit later
on and all that other kind stuff but
first let's do sure
that's right shout it out all right so
if you didn't see our latest movie
review it was the dead zone yeah maybe
three with Christopher Walken yeah great
movies it isn't really a good movie and
it's one that I always kind of forget
about what I'm thinking about like oh
really good Stephen King adaptations I
even forgot that David Cronenberg
directed that [ __ ] that's how if you
listen to 13 o'clock that's a must-see
TV right there you need to get that
thing on blu-ray or you watch it for
free on TV TV TV has like that's free
all the other transfer is actually
pretty good yeah yeah it actually looks
pretty nice you gotta put up with a few
commercial breaks but that's okay yeah I
prefer II honestly
- they don't cut the movies I don't mind
commercial yeah then I want that [ __ ]
on blu-ray I'm gonna add that to my
collection I got a lot of movies I've
got to go over the collection right and
I forgot another movie I was calling a
Stephen King psychic trilogy with dead
zone fire sir firestarter and shining
but I forgot Carrie you did yeah yeah
Carrie was telekinesis right and it was
a telekinesis that is a lot like
poltergeist
yeah and that was also actually really
good yeah yeah am I gonna get that one
too well yeah that's a classic right
also um I mentioned this on last week's
show but I put up four new t-shirt
designs on our azazel store which is
zazzle.com slash 13 o'clock
yeah hole designs man they're more Punk
Rakesh yeah which is yeah I think that's
I think that one will and the HH Holmes
what I think came out really nice demon
child yeah this man said I could we'll
see you guys to see it man said I could
yeah I need what I need that [ __ ] I'm
gonna wear that to the club yeah yeah
yeah get anything well yeah that's kind
of like well that's the reason I made
that sure yeah you could just wear that
and then you could just do anything
right and then it just will be like look
at the shirt and be like just pointed to
chest till I cross the [ __ ] you doing
man said that could bounce just turn
their back on me okay now they bounced
or anything you don't now so did a bell
on the which l1 which is referring back
to our via murder by witchcraft episode
I don't remember what never episode it
is right now cuz I'm probably half drunk
already
but you know that's how that is right
we're up I'm on that Keela again kela
Taylor yeah it's like tequila but
without the tea Oh is Kayla I drink what
the hell am i drinking you made some rum
sunset also I have one of your
ridiculous artichoke heart jars yeah you
can reach in there and start with your
hand if you I could put my whole head
that right it's like drinking out of a
bucket of popcorn right also in a couple
weeks
obviously our 100th episode is gonna go
up okay everybody likes I haven't really
started editing
yeah we're kind of recorded a bunch of
stuff we got to shoot a couple more
scenes this yeah I want to do some more
video for it everything but you got
actually like get to see earth well mugs
on camera yeah
so again also Shana yeah Shauna yeah and
they're gonna be on the show - yes
actually Sean I have Sean Akana co-host
for me yes thank you too much of a shot
he's just like I'm just gonna go back
the guys I love it just for boobs it was
just there and they're looking at you
you're not looking at their boobs can
stare well I don't know that they're
staring away oh yes you know they can do
it in the comfort of their art all right
okay
also if you would like to financially
support the show you can go to our
patreon page which is patreon.com slash
13 o'clock or you can go to our blog
which is 13 o'clock podcast at
wordpress.com and there's a link in the
sidebar to a PayPal account and I have
to give a very very very special shout
out to our fan Eric yeah Eric Thank You
Brooke Eric sent us just a magical
mystical 100 dollars for our hundredth
episode isn't that awesome dollars very
awesome that is so awesome
I was like so I was them yeah you may
look at one time PayPal there's you know
my yeah so yeah Eric appears in the
comments a lot you'll see who it is
we're talking about it might use this
last name their have permission yet
you'll see yeah and like that is super
awesome and it's like I just love when
would that happen
yeah cuz it's like so unexpected and
such happened that because it warms the
cockles of my heart that sounds nasty
it really does I mean you know hey we
all have cockles come on enough to know
what it sounds like something you kind
of steam and you serve it with pasta
like a cockleshell like a cockleshell
yeah well that's probably what it is
you know now I'm kind of like wondering
about the etymology of that kind of [ __ ]
what is that cockles and heart what else
oh you know at least
with somewhat that movie we saw the oh
and wait oh and also we have we also
have a new patron Oh named soupy okay
tell me you told me yeah yeah thanks
Sophie all right so you guys kick ass
thank you so much
the show is appreciated the show is
growing slowly but steadily this was
never intended to be one of those big
blockbuster mainstream shows that sells
out shells for other for other shows
with giant robots an explosion Michael
Bay yeah we always wanted to grow this
slowly but with a real good hardcore
interactive fanbase and that's why it's
going yeah cuz some of our supporters
have been with us for two years now and
you know my favorite thing is my
favorite thing is when I get messages
and I get them all the time saying you
guys are just like I want to hang out
with you guys yeah it's like you guys
are like my friends I just like it to
listen to you I'm like yeah I don't even
like to listen to us you guys do that is
so awesome it's like I I can't stand
well no I understand it because I just
listen to paranormal shows I'm a huge
art bell fan and now that Art's gone and
shows like this have a certain place
when you're trying to go to sleep at
night you want something to listen to
it's kind of interesting you know or if
you're commuting your own train or in a
car you want something to listen to it
unfortunately we're not doing these
every day if we did these every day we
wouldn't get anything else done with
their notebooks or anything like that
two a week is all we can have all but I
understand it you know I mean there
weren't very many good paranormal
programs on YouTube some of them were
very fact-based where there's a lot of
facts a lot of data but they're not very
entertaining a lot of them like you
don't know much about the host and then
you know you don't really can't really
make kind of a bond with it because
they're mostly just talking about the
case as much as I love particularly
there's a few true crime YouTube gyms
that I really like yeah like I love the
fact base the information is read but
thank God that wanted yeah I didn't want
to do another one like
one of those because there's a lot of
them already like that and one of them
are really good and yet really high
production value so you're not really
gonna beat them at their own game I was
like I just kind of wanted it to be just
what Ian you [ __ ] around yeah talking
about this is like a scene Nexus I mean
coming together and as a Nexus talking
about the scene
I like your hand gesture so I can't you
guys can't like doing like like little
circles like oh yeah
like a spirograph it's pretty cool yeah
we're like in the middle of the Nexus of
we're in the Nexus whatever well it also
were produced successful skylight being
in across the sphere but not buts about
the production of audiobooks and ebooks
really the main thing that we do is make
those damn audiobooks in terms of you
know the main contributed to the scene
we got some cool [ __ ] planned it's just
gotta get done the time takes a long
time to make these things but we got
some really cool class an extended
reboot of mammoth mountain poltergeist I
think it's really one of the what's the
trilogy that's early next year though
can get it and we have to get your
fiction that's audiobooks because really
audiobook is what's tales
yeah cuz the people are you got truck
drivers and computers and we already
have a pretty decent customer base so we
need to get those out on audiobook yeah
we I definitely won't get around to it
oh and also be sure to check out the 13
o'clock subreddit which was started by
our friend I think all the episodes are
up at this point and each episode has
its own has its own little forum so go
and check that out if you want to talk
to other fans all right so I have some
these are not like American stories or
anything like that but these just like
news this is like yeah okay this is the
news this is the news this is the news
remember I had a sing-song yeah well I
was like yeah where's your little jingle
that week since I forgot about that
that's actually kind of the same jingle
you saw a lot so so I haven't really hit
I haven't really had time to write any
things I'm just kind of pulling it out
you know thought I'm selling you know
what we were in the liquor store the
other day
yeah we're not drunk that's where yeah
we were in the liquor store the other
day and I heard that [ __ ] Neil
Diamond song Sweet Caroline this is the
new stinted like yeah and it's been
stuck in my head since that's - I do
like that - get that out of your head
you got to listen to the song you should
put that no that does not work for me it
does work for me I'll put it on listen
to it then immediately come coded fan is
just out of my head
you know on the plus side yeah when we
were at the house last weekend when
Shauna and Eric were here when we were
recording the show remember we saw the
video for the final countdown by Europe
oh yeah okay so that the whole entire
week until I went to the liquor store
and then the Neil Diamond song got sick
right so that's better that video is so
[ __ ] laughable because they're trying
to make it look guys high-tech as
possible and I remember thinking it
looked high-tech but really was nothing
more than just a camera on the end of a
[ __ ] helicopter sped up going across
the landscape where they go we're the
clock moving fast on it yeah I was like
yeah maybe was trying to make it look
like it was a cruise vessel is basha
yeah anyway so these are just like some
news stories that I got from like a news
of the weird site that amused me or
amused me this first one is kind of a
sad story but it's actually I'm gonna
file this under irony is a [ __ ] okay
also the universe hates us okay
so this is about Charlotte Fox who is 61
she was a mountain climber she actually
got to the top of Mount Everest in 1996
and she was actually part of the whole
mountaineering expedition that was the
basis of the documentary into thin air
very famous book and very famous
documentary she died recently
do you know how she died how she died
she fell down the stairs in her house
damn how old was she when she 61 that's
not that you like this kills me she
spent her entire life ferns our
professional career climbing up man
climbing up mountain
yeah and then dies at the falling down
the stairs does that suck or what yeah
as weird that's what I mean that is some
like [ __ ] yeah that's like being a
motorcycle racer and then getting on
your kids tricycle and killing yourself
oh damn tricycle that's like that's
exactly what it's like yeah and that
just really bummed me out some present
that it but yeah she has just dumb luck
dumb luck yeah that it's just since you
passed away but just goes to show you
can spend your whole life doing like
extreme [ __ ] show you like that kind of
[ __ ] but your house will kill you yeah
your house is the most dangerous place
where you spend most your time you know
it's gonna have to do with the situation
or maybe the lights were off I mean try
to go down stinking know you never know
because for real ye just one wrong move
and slip bust your ass adjust you've
done it many many you did at the club's
yes a lot of times yeah I caught you
coming down DJ booth that's right yeah
and a little shin yeah I still have a
skull of a notch on my chin perfect yeah
and I wasn't even drunk no slipped in
those [ __ ] laughs stairs are very
narrow and I have data platform boots on
yeah so now I'm like super super careful
and I probably can't juggle at the out
of stairs I stop do I hear people back
there snickering you busted he was
snickering at you cuz you busted yeah I
mean you know and honestly when I lived
in the UK the house that I lived in the
staircase was very narrow it was
carpeted yeah and it was always cold so
I always had socks on I fell down those
stairs so many times I can't even tell
you I mean at least they were carpeted
so it's like usually I just busted my
ass and I was fine but you know so that
really really sucks that she climbed
mountains our whole life and I've fallen
down the stairs yeah all right so this
next story comes from Denver alright
this happened on June 2nd at Rocky
Mountain High Colorado
oh now that's gonna be so much
this happened on June 2nd I don't know
if the guy's been named at this point
but they just call him an unnamed
off-duty FBI agent I did my picture he
was um at this bar he was dancing
somebody saw exactly what you saw the
video I figured I did see it it's just
as she was dancing and he did a backflip
and his gun came out of the holster it
fell to the floor discharged and
discharged and shot another dude in the
leg
yeah luckily no one killed yeah but
still getting shot the light just stops
it just added it just adds to the
ongoing problems that the FBI is having
right now with their image they're not
the organization they once were
I mean hey FBI agents they they can go
out and party like anyone else yeah
seriously that is a dumbest there you do
I'm gonna go out and drink yeah here's
something else I made a living sidearm I
made a living carrying a gun with the
army you don't go to a club don't take
it to the bar with your piece why don't
you do that drinkin yeah accidents are
gonna happen or you're gonna get loaded
and somebody's gonna push the wrong
button right that's just that's just bad
judge and it's still it's a federal
offense stick to carry a concealed
firearm into a bar now if you're law
enforcement drinking off-duty I don't
know they may legally be able to do that
but I doubt it
yeah that's the sound right Eames like
sounds like a violation I would think
that probably cost him his badge uh yeah
drinking whiz gun I don't know I'm not
anti-gun I'm not Andy got at all well I
don't begrudge and also I don't begrudge
people like even FBI agents they
probably have more reason to drink than
I do
yeah yeah but like don't take your gun
with you and more maybe they face that
[ __ ] in the car yeah just leave in the
car you guys should do you have to bring
it in with you that just seems really
dumb if you feel it somebody's gonna
jump your ass and whip
for being an FBI agent don't go out or
don't tell anybody
don't tell me that's easy - yeah I don't
know what I don't know what model of
pistol that was for any modern pistol
should not discharge when drop that's
what I always think so there's a lawsuit
there I couldn't I feel like he maybe
reached for it and pulled the trigger no
I saw he was just dancing it's like it
fell out of his pants
and it hit and it landed on the land
it's not hard for them to discharge by
accident I thought well if anything can
happen but I couldn't really identify
the model it look like some kind of
Smith like Smith & Wesson yeah but that
shouldn't have happened but if they land
the right way no firing pin spring in
the world is gonna keep that firing pin
to the rear and just that concussion
alone can cause it to go forward here's
a nothing jack hole if you're gonna take
your pistol into the bar on chamber
around that way hit the racket just that
way you have to rock this side you have
to rack the slide to begin the firing
sequence you don't mean you're not under
that much threat you know I mean it
doesn't take much to Rack slide now I
understand if you're in you know if
you're if the other hand is occupied
because you're wrestling with a guy I'm
getting into tactics I'm getting the
small arm jackets I wouldn't take it I
wouldn't do it but yeah and like this
poor guy I mean the guy that got shot
his name was Tom ran I feel bad for the
dude u.s. the only four years old it's
funny because he didn't realize he'd
been shot at first cuz you don't you're
right um he just thought somebody had
said a firecracker off and then he
looked at and his leg was all red the
only good thing to come out of this
we'll other than him not being this old
because that easily could have happened
but the only good thing to come out of
this is that the Mile High distillery
has told Tom Reddington that he has free
drinks forever right get drinks whatever
he wants to all right now this last
story I thought was kind of funny but
this having an Oregon also on June 2nd
sheriff's deputies waited for a tow
truck to remove a 2003 Toyota Camry from
the side of the road
23 year-old Anthony Clark of Grants Pass
walked up to the car and told the
deputies he was going to steal it he
walks up to the deputies and said I'm
gonna steal that car that you're waiting
to show he then got into the car and
drove off leading officers on a 40-mile
chase through Ashland Talent in Phoenix
it wasn't his car no okay crashing in
defenses and driving the wrong way on
something
balls man when officers finally sent the
card this is the best part yeah Clark
ran into a mobile home park where he was
arrested trying to steal another car
okay the deputies reported Clark
admitted taking LSD and said he thought
he was inside a real-life version of
Grand Theft Auto awesome dude I thought
I was at like that one I need to you
like that why do you the cops are
sitting on the car [ __ ] like step
aside gee shit's mine take they take
what go you I guess okay if I was if I
was if I was pride just give me but like
criminal mischief or something like that
anybody you know under the influence in
public something like that a man I think
that's all he was charged with it says
he's accused of driving under the
influence of intoxicants and second
degree criminal mischief yeah yeah cuz
you can almost argue temporary insanity
because he's I know the influence of LSD
I thought I was in Grand Theft Auto yeah
yeah just like been there probably in 90
days so let's kind of get into the main
part of this story which is the infamous
Lost Colony yeah this is a good topic
this is a good table how we doing on
time we got time okay it seemed like we
were going on and on and on for a long
time we always go on and on I know okay
didn't know if we were ready for a
commercial all right well we might be it
was a Keela in the room I might need
another one
I can Pookie we can always pause it like
go make another one that cute you want
to do that okay pause it
okay I recharged it it's all recharged I
know now we we got refills yeah I'm
ready for the show
really yeah way what's not real serious
topic this is pretty simple yeah it is
interesting because they haven't really
found any definitive evidence that
happened to these people
yeah we're going back to the 1580s yeah
Queen Elizabeth had long been wanting to
establish a colony in the New World
kind of fill England's coffers type of
stuff yeah which I didn't really work
out well no they never really made any
profit off these colonies but yeah I
remember reading about it right you know
how that goes yeah but the thing that
ended up being a knight managed it
eventually but they never really made
money with these here's the thing like
everything back then was like such a
huge yeah undertaking yeah the expenses
yeah it's like think of you just had to
go okay well we're gonna go to the New
World you're just across the whole
[ __ ] Atlantic Ocean it took months
and months it was lasting all these
supplies all these people was the
equivalent of trying to colonize Mars it
was more like a thing a national pride
than it was profit-making now the
colonies themselves eventually became
successful but not to the Empire's
advantage it was actually to their
detriment because they all declared
independence yeah they're like [ __ ] off
once they started to make money they
just broke off yes he was as you were
cuz why you know their way the [ __ ]
across the ocean and then the colonies
were basically always treated his second
third class citizens any right back in
the empire so there was even it was they
were the ones even though they were
doing a lot of the work on that they
were doing all the work in that area
when you really look at the details it
was like it was like a no-brainer that
they were gonna break off but yeah they
couldn't look into the future that was
you know sometimes hundreds of years
later you know depending on which Empire
I mean you know Spanish Empire also was
doing in Mexico and Central South
America yeah now before the very famous
quote unquote Lost Colony there had been
a couple of incursions
or a couple of attempts to settle the
area of Roanoke Island the first one was
in 1585 now a lot of [ __ ] happened
because it seemed like the settlers
arrived when they first arrived they
were actually the Nate
were pretty friendly we're pretty
welcoming they kind of established kind
of a require first they were trading and
things of that nature [ __ ] went sour
kind of quickly the guy that was in
charge of the initial these were mostly
like military guys and stuff like that
yeah not really any diplomats not really
anything like that so you know there was
some misunderstandings there was some
bad blood there was like oh you guys
stole a silver cup you did this that the
other and then yeah and then one of the
dudes that was running the original you
know group of settlers beheaded the
chief of one of the tribes yeah and you
know obviously they didn't really take
too kindly to that
right so you know there was already some
[ __ ] going on before the you know
quote-unquote lost colonists even got
there right you also have to mention the
fact that everything that the Spanish
were doing in Mexico around that time
right with the conquistadors and the
conquistador you know there's a lot of
misconceptions of what it what actually
happened with Hernan Cortes and the
conquistadors the way that's been spun
through the British version of the tale
that we've inherited here in the United
States about that you know 40
conquistadors brought down the Aztec
empire not really true no not true it's
not how that happened was more like
Hernan Cortes led a revolt of a bunch of
Mesoamerican cities against the central
city whereas now Mexico's a.m. the
Indian name is escaping - stayed in my
mind at this point but when you really
start to study what had happened in the
in the Americas during the early part of
what we would call the colonization
period this time is not really as you
really thought it was thought of that
stuff's kind of been politically skewed
over the years by competing European
empires the British Empire made the
Spanish look bad the Spanish made the
bridge wants their own people to look
exactly best possible like you know what
I mean right we've inherited a lot of
those stories from the age of empire
that's a lot of times where those
stories came from well that's kind of an
interesting thing and you know when I
was kind of looking into cuz I've been
reading like a bad of a lot of American
folklore and things
nature and you know I was gonna talk a
little bit about on the show but we kind
of decided to just go more in this
direction with this one case but the
interesting thing about it is that how
so much of the stuff that you learn in
school I know that they have to simplify
it because you know history is you know
immensely complex and it's very hard to
like distill things down to you know
teach it to little kids in like a brief
period of time so you have to leave a
lot of [ __ ] out but it's interesting on
stuff like this gets filtered through
different lenses depending on who's
telling the story yeah one of the big
lies that we were all taught is that the
Native Americans were one race they
weren't they were a bunch of competing
tribes that had different histories of
their own some of them were people that
had walked across ice bridges from China
some of them were Clovis type people
that have walked across ice bridges that
came from Europe some of them were more
kind of like Mesoamericans that kind of
walked up from Mexico so and they all
had their own languages and their own
cultures in their own tribal and / kind
of semi national identities and they
were worn with each other for thousands
of years before the British and the
Spanish empires ever showed up here that
kind of plays into the story that we're
gonna tell you about the Lost Colony of
Roanoke not all these Indian tribes were
the same they were not monolithic
they were diverse and honestly um you
know some of these first incursions into
Roanoke Island were met by some kind of
hostile tribes and also some that were
kind of friendly yeah they actually had
two Native Americans one of them was
named man Thao and one was named Juan
Chazy
I think that's how you pronounce them
and they actually wanted to help and
they actually went back to England like
as yes right this was before the lost
colonists you know came yeah that's
another misconception the Indians or I'm
calling the minions because that's just
a common American is that American names
didn't know anything about the white men
didn't know anything about Europe no
[ __ ] well a lot of them had been to
Europe at this period so usually we're
going back and forth a lot of times like
with Myles Standish when they showed up
when that colony was established the
Indians said hey you know white people
are here and then a few months later
Squanto showed up and he was an Indian
that they knew about from another tribe
who had just got back come back from
England and he spoke English they used
him as a translator so Indians knew
about Europe they didn't know all the
little details but they knew about white
people yeah and like I said some of them
had been there like some good when his
ambassadors and that definitely happened
in this case with these two particular
men that went back to England for a
short time now this is before the lost
colonists got there as I said there was
another attempt to start a colony but
then there was this whole evidently
there was kind of a I guess it was a
misunderstanding
where they're like well there's one
tribe that's friendly to the colonists
there's another tribe that's hostile to
the colonists and had attacked them on
more than one occasion yeah and I
believe that they had actually killed
one of the colonists but then like the
friendly tribes like okay well we're
gonna get like a peace summit kind of
together we're gonna sort all this [ __ ]
out and so they established a day to do
that so the American Indians didn't show
up at the time they were supposed to or
there was some kind of thing and then
the colonists got all pissed off about
it yeah go trampling off into the woods
and they find a Native American village
like the first one they came across and
there's like we're just gonna slaughter
everybody yeah these must be the bad
guys these must be the bad guys yeah
well turns out that that was the tribe
that was friendly to them yeah so you
can imagine so yeah you can see how you
can see have that plate right and you
can imagine the confusion imagine if
some Cherokee went to Europe and tried
to figure out the difference between the
Dutch the Germans and the British in the
French today I'll look away all the
compare but you know we look at it well
those are all different languages well
the Indians were the same way there were
all different languages they were all
different cultures and in some cases
they were different races yeah or
different ethnic groups of the same race
even they would go to war with each
other there's another misconception that
these tribes were ancient no most most
people will say that a tribe lasted
about a hundred years they would blend
in with other tribes and then break up
and form other tribes they were in
constant you know constant flux yeah a
good example would be kind of like the
the Apache the Apache weren't around for
very long they know when the pachi were
formed and about
Pachi were broke up and never a war with
everybody and mostly Indians it's just
like any other civilization you know I
mean some countries are just a constant
war with other countries well like I
said anytime you have another tribe in
trying to like make an incursion on your
resources yeah you're gonna fight again
yeah probably yeah life is a struggle
they're kind of competing for resources
and and I feel like that's kind of you
know maybe it's maybe it's better now
but like I remember being fed a very
simplistic what was going on you know
what I mean you know the Indians were
players they were players in the game
they were men trying to get things done
any way you could get it done under
those circumstances there's kind of this
Hollywood idea that that Native American
tribes were kind of these pushover
victims no no I would probably put most
Native American tribes at the level of
samurai even up into the 1800 they ended
up helping out the colonists Elias I
mean the early colonists uh first came I
mean thank or not I'm talking about
battle prowess yeah these guys weren't
victims they were good at what they did
yeah in fact most of the early
literature that right white people wrote
about the Native Americans all the way
up until maybe the 1800 or 1900 was
nothing but just mad crush man on man
man crush about how great Indians were
yeah that they were perfect physical
specimens that they were great warriors
they had great equipment and tactics
miles Standish had to prove himself to
the Indians and you know he wrote back
saying these dudes are fantastic
what they do they were like Special
Forces troops well from the Native
American standpoint you'd have to think
that most of the colonists that came
there they probably saw soft soft weak
kind of city boys you know we're one
step away from wearing makeup and
powdered wigs yeah I mean that's a
feminine city boys that's how the
Indians saw these guys well yeah and you
can't blame yeah I mean because you know
they just kind of lived off the land and
their yeah it was a very warrior culture
most of them were and to tell it true to
tell it the way it really happened most
of the time even in the period of the
United States and the existence of the
United States
Native American forces kicked ass on the
US Army most of the time and because
they had better tactics Maidan had
better weapons well and they were more
familiar with the terrain yeah and the
better tactics and yeah [ __ ] like that
and there's this Hollywood concept that
Indians ran around in the 1800s with
bows and Spears no they used
lever-action repeating rifles they had
the best weapons money could buy really
they were not defeated MIT by military
means what happened was is that the
landscape changed cars came there was
railroads and you just couldn't maintain
the Indian lifestyle you have the good
job yeah I mean yeah I couldn't just run
around people homeland you know you're
walking through people's grazing
territory you know so really it wasn't
the Indians we needs we're not defeated
Indian lifestyle just phased out that's
really what happened there's a lot of
interbreeding
if you're an American you've been here
longer than three generations you have
some Native American in you that's
pretty much there there's a lot of
absorption to interbreeding and I'm kind
of thinking that that's probably what
happened with the Mandan the Indian
tribe was wiped out because everybody
married them all right because they were
known as being like the best looking in
their area so he's married white people
I mean the white guys would go there
they didn't have wives they married any
women the city of Salem was or the town
of Salem was mostly mixed race between
British and Indian people and the
history says that right there in the
town logs and like I said that is one of
the main theories about what happened in
the loss column
they just first we're going to take a
break because we're a little bit past
the halfway point but that's a day so we
will be back in just a few minutes and
we will talk more about the Lost Colony
of Roanoke
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay everybody Ginny's got some new
shirt designs up four of them really
good ones to Atlanta Ripper who put
Bella in the which out the HH Holmes
murder castle and of course demon child
cuz man said he could these are updated
designs I think they look really cool
Jenny did a great job
bottom where they found making jetty
they were very fun and thank you very
much I think they came out right yeah it
really good they're very high quality
shirts Jenny and I we're sure our own
shirts at certain times when we're
trying to put spotlight on ourselves and
you can put a spotlight on yourselves if
you go ahead and pick up on these shirts
today you guys are gonna love them mix
in the description
WWL com at 13 o'clock yeah so go check
out our store at wwl com / 13 o'clock we
got these four cool new t-shirt designs
plus all our old ones if you'd rather
get one of the old ones but these ones
are awesome and you should check them
out they're also available in women's
cut they look really cute JD's got some
so thank you go check them out ok and
we're back when you talk about the Lost
Colony the famous Lost Colony this
happened in 1587 this was a group of 115
colonists I think it was 87 men 17 women
11 children I think was if that
mathematically adds up right I think
that's about what it was so they're
gonna go start a new colony now the
leader of it was a guy named John white
who was an artist also a friend of Sir
Walter Raleigh it was kind of the guy
that was you know bankrolling the whole
thing or he wasn't bankrolling it but he
was queen elizabeth's you know bring a
man and she's gotta tell him yeah so
white was the governor and they tried to
establish this colony at some point they
need someone to go back to England for
more supplies John White is recruited I
guess is the right word because I think
John White was like I didn't really want
to go I mean he had a daughter there he
had a granddaughter Virginia Dare who
was significantly the first English
child born on American shores born in
the new world so he was like well I
didn't really want to go but everyone
else insisted so some historians have
speculated that the reason that the
other colonists in
listed that John White was the one that
go back to England to get supplies for
the colonists was because he was kind of
slinging his dick around a little bit
with the Native Americans and everything
and they thought that it was he was not
being diplomatic and he was gonna get
them in trouble
so he's like why don't you go back to
England get us some [ __ ] and then we'll
try and like settle everything down you
know it was kind of a thing like that he
left only about a month after they got
there and like set up the colony now he
was supposed to come right back or as
right back as you could come like I mean
the sail over the entire Atlantic Ocean
however when he got back to England
turns out that whole war between England
and Spain was happening and Elizabeth
was like no we need every single ship to
fight the Spanish Armada so you are not
going back there even though like I said
his daughter was there as granddaughter
was there so he didn't end up coming
back to Roanoke for three years three
years for him to get back now he comes
back to where he left the Roanoke colony
and there's nothing there three years
later now I from memory I thought there
was some stuff there there were no fee
there there were no people yet right the
only clues obviously the houses the
forts and everything like that had been
disassembled yeah they found a tree that
had C R o carved into it yeah and part
of the posts like on the outside of like
a fort or whatever yeah and it said
Croatoan Croatoan so many carve your
word Croatoan yeah into the wood also in
the woods they found some trunks that
had some things that there's like books
and stuff things that you don't need for
survival sounds yeah it seems like stuff
that maybe they're like well we'll come
back a turret for that right so it
didn't look like because here's the
thing they had established that they're
like look if you had to leave quickly or
leave in duress yeah put across like
leave a cross symbol they didn't leave
that okay so they did have time to
disassemble the village or you know
whatever they had built you're right
they did have time to carve Croatoan
which was the name of an eye
as well as the name of a Native American
tribe that they were kind of friends
with right so that's where he assumed
they had gone right that's making quite
a drastic assumption though when you
think about it could something like that
just been scrawled down by a guy who was
doing guard duty because he had heard
that word or was that actually a message
to where they were I kind of feel like
what because from everything that I've
read it does seem like I mean they
didn't expect white to be gone that long
obviously they thought he was gonna come
back like in a couple of months with
stuff like with food and everything and
tools and whatnot they weren't expecting
him to be gone three years but from
everything I've read they did establish
they're like look if we're not here when
you come back we'll leave a message as
to where we went to now the fact that
somebody went to the trouble to carve
Croatoan you know not only in that thing
on the front of the fort like the bro
host but also the scarp CRO in the tree
but not carve a cross above it and like
I said they obviously didn't leave
quickly because they had time to
disassemble everything right so they
weren't in a hurry so this is why I
don't feel like because you know some
theories about what happened to these
peoples oh well the Native Americans
have to stop and wipe them out but out
that I doubt that too because honestly
they've never found any bodies the scene
wouldn't look like that if it was
exactly if it was an Indian mask it
seemed very deliberate it seems like
okay whoa we don't like it here or we
need to go elsewhere you know who knows
okay then I'll own it were they on the
island or were certain in each because
you say there was an island called
Croatoan the island is full now is
called Hatteras Island okay but back
then it was called Croatoan Island the
tribe is called the Croatan tribe and
they lived there on that I they lived
there on that island okay did they ever
go to that Island to look for well okay
okay here's what ended up happening okay
so white he comes there he sees the
message Croatoan and he immediately says
oh well that's where they went because
we established a code that we were gonna
say that's where you know you tell us
where where are you going and then he
found the trunks with the books and
stuff he's like okay cool
that just must mean
they were gonna come back for the self
and everything is fine he's like I'm
gonna sail it was fit it was about 50
miles I think he's like I'm gonna sail
down to Croatoan and see what's what so
there if I can find out where I was away
it was 50 miles 50 miles was a long way
away a new phase now he attempted to go
I think the first time it was a storm
like the second time in any case he
tried to go like three times and he was
never able to get there okay and then he
ended up having to go back to England so
he never she never verified it went back
to the New World
so there's a chance at least some of
them did go to Croatoan that's what I'm
thinking and it's like yes it's creepy
yes it's mysterious but they said where
they were going okay I mean that's what
they said they were gonna go they said
we're gonna tell you where we're going
we went to Croatoan but he couldn't get
there okay so you know and he couldn't
get there to check right I don't think
they were killed all of them well okay
I'm gonna go ahead and throw in my two
cents at this point all right knowing
what I know about what the colonies were
organized back in those days okay they
were organized very poorly a lot of
times they had leadership that was unfit
for command what I think happened is
that the colony started to fail whoever
was in charge really had lost the
confidence of most of the colonists I'm
I'm thinking having actually lived in
military type situations out in the
field where you're worried about [ __ ]
very basic necessities like food and
water and you know anything like shelter
okay because I've actually lived that
life I'm gonna go ahead and say that
that group probably had had splintered
into it at least two factions I'm gonna
say to whoever wrote Croatoan was
probably the leadership in other words
the official leadership the one that
England had decided you know because a
lot of times the leadership of the
colony was appointed by the monarchy you
and they didn't have the licenses you
are in charge wouldn't surprise me if
the person in charge decided to go to
Croatoan with his faction and then I
also had to think that there was another
faction and I think the other faction
joined the idiots that's what I'm
thinking
yeah because there's a lot of problems
with the European lifestyle and
European system and the European way of
thinking in that place in time the
European lifestyle just didn't work in
the new world to the 1500s it didn't
work in the new world and really until
the 1900s when you think about it true
okay I think a sizable portion of that
colony went engine that's what we used
to call it in the 1800's going engine
right they almost kind of saw it as
defecting it's where you know what [ __ ]
all this European [ __ ] okay because
there was a lot of different [ __ ] in the
European society back then there was a
lot of religious forces you know things
he had to do to be part of your religion
there was a lot of monarchy type stuff
like following the king weird rules that
colonies had to follow because the king
put him on that just didn't work in the
new world that would have been like a a
very theoretical situation you know I
mean but life in the new world was about
the here and now so there was no
advantage of following that stuff I
think they just joined Indian tribes
that's kind of what I'm learning an
Indian tribe would have been the best
thing you could do if you were a
colonist they had it made they didn't
have to worry about Christendom they
didn't have to worry about monarchy they
could live in the here and now they
could have a lot of fun inside tribe
they were very liberated they had
concepts like free love they all
different kinds of Honor type systems
you know I mean men could be men in that
system they could earn their way up
Irish guys and English guys did very
well in Indian tribes and so did the
women a lot you hear all these stories
later on even in the 1800s about white
women being captured by the Indians they
even attack these tribes to get those
women back in the middle the night all
those women did vanish
cuz they'd all go back we went on
perfectly our perfect [ __ ]
and this is something those are nice too
this is something that white guys of the
time had a hard time grappling with is
that Native American men could beat out
white men of those days and it was a
better life general it was a better
lifestyle in a European lifestyle in the
colonies you lived in a basically a
filthy town that wasn't really well
supplied and it was tightly controlled
either by a theocracy or a monarchy the
living wasn't that good or you could
live a mobile lifestyle you know there
was very clean living fresh meat fresh
water kind of like you could get you a
man or you can get you a woman you can
wear practical clothing ok made out of
buckskin and leather it was a better
lifestyle and that's something that
we'll see how that would be very
appealing yes Emily to the women I would
think and the women did not have to
worry about Christian rules then it was
wasn't as tightly patriarchal yeah you
know what you know a woman could be what
she was worth you know it's all about
she if she was good at doing certain
things she was recognized that way and a
lot of these values that Americans hold
dear today actually were kinda picked up
from the Indian tribes by osmosis
including democracy and many of those
you know yeah you can go back to Athens
in Greece but Indian tribes were kind of
democratic too because yeah probably
more than the European more than
Europeans at that time those Congress so
it was it made more sense in the New
World to be an Indian than it did to be
a European if you want to talk about
lifestyle they had a superior lifestyle
and and even all the way up into the
1800s they kicked ass on the American
army most of the time yeah the American
army made a lot of mistakes they
massacred the wrong people or massacred
people for reasons that really didn't
we're stupid you can find a lot of the
details and the commanding officers
going wait a minute why am I being
ordered to do this this doesn't make any
sense these aren't the Indians we're
looking for the Star Wars you know but
the 1800s was chaos most of most of
reality is a chaos really what you think
about it you know to me it's the truth
and when you have centrally commanded
governments that are far away telling
their troops to do certain things those
troops like why the hell we being told
to do this this
this is what I always thought it's like
look whoever is telling you to do that
they are an entire ocean away yeah not
gonna know what the [ __ ] they don't know
what's going on right right
even if somebody narcs on you it's gonna
be months before anybody finds that [ __ ]
right you could get away with all crap
yeah so I don't really know why anyone
would want so here's the thing like I
gotta feel like and there was also in
1585 John White had made a map it's
actually very accurate to you know what
it was like at the time now some people
have noted that at some point he had put
like a patch over one little part of the
map which was a pretty common thing to
do back in the day because you know when
you're making a map you couldn't like
start all over because you know they
were expensive to bank so you would just
put a patch over something that you
messed up now underneath this patch
there's like a little for pointed star
shape indicating that there was maybe a
fourth now this was not um on Roanoke
Island it was not on Croatoan Island it
was inland it was about 50 miles inland
yeah so some have speculated that maybe
they either went to Croatoan Island and
later went here in an arse or one group
went to Croatoan one group went inland
yes John White actually had talked about
going about 50 miles inland yeah well
that's where this map was it wouldn't
surprise me if the leadership of the
Roanoke colony tried to get to Croatoan
Island yeah but I think I think what
we're talking about here is like maybe
between five and ten guys okay I think
most of them went engine but they were
afraid it but you know the people who
were in charge of the colony were afraid
of hanging and getting in trouble so
they went to a fallback position where
they thought it would be safe to wait
for like rescue but that didn't work out
that's what I think happened you only
talking about four or five guys maybe
ten guys it'd be easy for a small group
like that to vanish with it without
worries okay and I think that's what
happened yes and they get busted up into
two groups the command went to Croatoan
Island everybody else joined the Indian
tribes that's probably I feel like a
like I don't know got a role basically
cuz here's the thing in
years particularly when the jamestown
settlement which you know nowadays is
considered the oldest americans that you
know yeah well right because Roanoke
colony yes that was look at the details
of how that became successful relates
really closely to the situation I'm
talking about now that colony cotta
quote-unquote went engine well yeah okay
the Native Americans helped I don't have
to go engine if you have to think on it
here's our know exactly you're dumb if
you don't like right there look we've
lived here for hundreds a life Roanoke
had a big problem with going engine and
it split into two that's what I think it
might have now I don't think like I said
there are a lot of theories about what
happened to these people - these 115
people you know some people are like oh
well the Indians killed them to do like
the Spanish killed them because you know
I don't yeah the Spanish were kind of
pissed off at the English too because
yeah they were privateering all along
the coast and you know radio ships and
[ __ ] like that yes so yeah it's possible
Alliance for the area I'm like I don't
think it's very likely because they
never found any bodies right in the
whole fact that they left clues to where
they had gone I mean yeah I know three
years have passed so some other ship
might have happen in the interim but I
do kind of feel like they had a plan
they're like okay well we're going here
maybe with Mateo who was their friend
one of the Mid American tribes so he's
like well maybe he said well why don't
you just come live with my people maybe
all of them did that maybe some of them
said no we're gonna go to this other
location who knows what happened but I
don't think they were all wiped out no I
don't think I think they integrated and
honestly when Jamestown was established
yeah there were some reports doesn't
white Indians right yeah yes yes
physical evidence of this but they were
that you know we've seen Native American
tribes where they had like blue eyes
blonde hair or they have like English
sounding names yeah they found like some
kind of English sort of like pottery and
things like that at some points along
that so there's a possibility I kind of
think they integrated yeah
you know yeah it was 115 people some of
them might have died somebody might have
starved who knows but it's like I kind
of feel like they just became integrated
and after a little while yeah nobody
really knew the difference anymore by
all of the written accounts from those
days from the 15 16 and 17 hundreds
white people and Native American people
kind of took to each other pretty easily
yeah I think what ended up happening is
that most of the Roanoke tribe took
husbands and wives from the Native
American population they just blended
right in
hi and there are so many reports later
on in the 1700s about Boise's Indians
they're like white people they look like
white people and that's part of what
you're talking about the other part of
what you're talking about is that
there's a lot of archaeological evidence
that possibly in the northeastern area
many of the Native American tribes were
kind of like the Clovis people okay they
built a lot of things like Clovis people
there seems to have been an ice sheet
that connected parts of Ireland to the
new world we're talking about thousands
and thousands of years ago so some of
the people in the northeast of the
United States and then fifteen hundreds
may have been basically descended some
Europeans had walked across ice bridges
because that was definitely happening
across the ice bridge to China and I
think I did have it before there just
because you show up in a boat in the
1517 year the first one there there was
a lot of migration and that's what I
said that's the whole thing about
Christopher Columbus and why the [ __ ]
away
yeah Columbus Day because it's like he
wasn't even the first one here nothing
his writings show up why he didn't even
land in the continental United States no
islands to the Vikings have been here
what five hundred years before him yeah
something like that
and you in if the Vikings could do it
then you then chances are it was done
thousands of years before that on limit
is that yeah I think you would think
yeah I think the American continents
have been undergoing migration for tens
of thousands of years it wouldn't
surprise you and the least right now let
me mention something here about this is
something that's kind of come up about
the whole Lost Colony of Roanoke saying
and this is the Dare stones now I
just a bunch of documentaries about this
today in preparation for the show the
History Channel back when they actually
showed history and not a bunch of stupid
reality show yeah actually made a very
informative documentary about the Lost
Colony of Roanoke who's very
entertaining I thought they also had one
of a later vintage that's called America
unearthed and it was about the dare
stones now the dude that's on it I can't
remember what his name was but he's he's
supposed to be like a geologist there's
something geologic historian I don't
know what his name was he came across on
this show American Earth like a giant
[ __ ] ass bag no seriously
okay ask and ask can be a bag yeah it's
like okay here's the thing and this is
what I hate I hate that the History
Channel and the Discovery Channel and
stuff like that I think that they do
like you know and I'm making little
bunny rabbit ears like ironic you know
finger quotes documentaries about this
yeah well I don't okay I don't like this
whole I'm a you know scientist or
researcher or whatever I have
information that hundreds and thousands
of other experts don't have and I'm
right and they're wrong because my gut
tells me so
yeah I really really hate that and I
kind of feel like this show was like
that this guy was basically coming from
the preconceived end that the dare
stones which I'll get to in a minute
were genuine and so then he goes around
like arguing with experts museum
curators archaeologists make an ass out
of making an ass out of himself why is a
dare stop tell the Dare stones okay it's
basically it's a series of 48 stones
that were supposedly carved by another
first one they said was carved by
Eleanor White dare who was the daughter
of John White the bear and also the
mother of Virginia Dare the first baby
okay the first English baby born on in
the new world so these are all supposed
to have been carved by her or by other
the lost colonists and left at various
points around the area saying what
happened to them problem with this
now I'm willing to give the first dare
sown the benefit of the doubt this was
discovered in 1937 by a tourist and he
came across this stone it had like a
cross carved into it and it said Ananias
dare who was her husband and Virginia
Dare that was her daughter the baby went
hence unto heaven 1591 says she sang her
husband her baby died in 1591 which was
about four years after the colony was
settled it says any Englishman showed
John White now this stone might be
genuine I don't want to say 50/50 but
it's like some experts that have looked
at it so like yeah it looks like it
comes from the time it looks like you
know this could be genuine
however the 47 other ones that said what
happened to like oh the Indians killed
all but seven of the settlers and then
we went here we went there we ended up
in [ __ ] Georgia where yeah and it's
like those ones those only came about
after the person who received the first
stone was like oh we want to know what
happened to the colonists maybe there
are more of these somewhere and then
this was during the Depression in the US
right so people were like 2 Chainz Yeah
right and they're like conveniently a
stone cutter was like yeah I found a
ship some more of these and the and the
guy that like the guy that was that
wanted to see them was like offering
like 500 bucks like reward or something
like that yeah so you know and so now
there's like this whole saga of like
what happened to this yeah I think
that's larger [ __ ] so this whole I
was watching this quote-unquote History
Channel document and it's on YouTube and
I have to say my faith in humanity was
restored because pretty much 99% of the
commenters were like what the [ __ ] is
this [ __ ] right yeah it's like he
doesn't know anything and he's like
going around so he may very well be a
geologist but he's coming at it from the
perspective I think that all of these
stones are genuine therefore every other
single expert who disagrees means just
gonna argue with them and
and like and I like that the one museum
curator guy who's actually has like [ __ ]
from the actual sites it's just kind of
like those are fakes everybody knows
those are fakes
and here's the reason why I think a lot
of her the first one may or may not be a
fake I'm willing to concede maybe the
first one is genuine but all the first
one says is that my husband and baby
died please tell my dad you know here we
are it's 1591 or whatever that's pretty
much all it says right the other ones
like I said have this whole epic saga
about where they went in all this other
country but the problem is that a lot of
the stones okay for one thing
if you made those stones where would you
put them so people could find them well
no see the problem is that the stone
cutter found them that's a huge problem
experts in Roanoke colony or Leia these
are fakes yeah they're like we're not
sure about the first one because that
was found by a different dude like your
time but it's like these other ones that
suddenly appeared after there was a
reward spying all these little stones of
messages a song that's writing it's like
it just seems like that yeah it seems
like what we wanted to know what
happened the Roanoke colonies like
[ __ ] age it's not the only thing that
makes me think the first one might be
fake is that it's signed and real the
first I might be real no the only thing
that makes you think the first one might
be fake okay all right is that it's
signed e/wd Eleanor White dare yeah in
that era women didn't usually sign
things like that okay
they're like another thing that is not
so much the first one but all the other
ones they're like here's the thing the
spelling on that one it's all Roman
letters you know gothic letters okay to
the spelling is consistent which it
wasn't yes I'm right there no
standardized spelling but there was no
standardized spelling back then also a
couple of the words that were used in
some of the messages not in common usage
such as it's a fake reconnoitre Oh Riko
actually was not invest 1900s no first
publish used was 1707 okay but that was
an rican order became a common term used
in the 1900s yeah like I said first
published use was the early 1700s yeah
but later than these foot stones that's
[ __ ] like it's not impossible right
but it's very unlikely so I kind of feel
like I'm on the fence about the first
one maybe that no maybe that's not it's
big I kind of am leaning for the first
one being fake as well that's the only
one that hasn't been true but the other
$47 oh no certainly the Roanoke colony
vanished without a trace because of ass
Indians have fine ass well of course
because you have to adapt to the new way
of life situation like in the new world
the Indians were the Masters of that
game they do have a live and prosper in
that environment you couldn't do it the
European Way in that day these are human
beings you got to get laid it's very
true alright and 30s had all that ok the
union's had all that and by all accounts
these Indians were a sight to see
well like I said they've been living
there for hundreds a lot of years so
they were adapted to their environment
yeah you know they were all in great
shape yeah everybody said they were
fantastic physical specimens and that
they were they have lots of virtue
masculine and feminine virtue and I
would think the colonists themselves
probably we're not the best England had
to offer so you know biology takes over
you know it doesn't you see these
good-looking people that are making it
they're prospering are you gonna side
with them or are you gonna side with
some far away coverage you know these
pay less your f---ing [ __ ] it
was a far away alien government that
couldn't help you actually that
government didn't like you you were one
of their basically hood rats and I think
one of the documentaries that watched
like put this in a pretty good way
there's like you know these English
people they were used to being able to
like go to a shop where I weapons and
clothing dude you go to the new
you can't do that you have to live
nothing is there you have to build
everything your cell right to farm every
day it would be very appealing
Rana came there for people that have
lived there for hundreds thousands of
years right and they knew what they were
doing they knew the land they knew how
to live off of it and by all accounts
they were like Special Forces commandos
yeah all right these guys were like
[ __ ] super good shape they could run
rings around you yeah I do kind of feel
you're gonna biology is gonna take over
okay so I kind of feel like I like the
mystery of the Lost Colony like I said
the whole the whole detail of Croatoan
being like that used to creep me out
when I was a kid before I knew that that
was an actual place and I was like wow
that's a creepy then but honestly I
think all that happened was that either
they all went to its particular either
they all went to Croatoan and then move
somewhere else later on or they split
into two factions they split into two
one faction went to Croatoan one faction
went to this other place inland where
the where it was marked on the map and
they integrated into a Native American
society in there henceforth Scott just
diluted yeah I kind of think that's
probably all that happened I don't think
they got slaughtered I know think maybe
some of them died of other things maybe
some of them doesn't try to knows but
you have to understand that the
Europeans that did not go to Croatoan
Island the ones that wanted to integrate
really kind of would have been seen as
exotic by the Indians yeah it means
would have been like wow these people
are different and if they're trying to
learn from you then they must be okay
yeah I think they got married yes well
II got married and I also want to
mention too that there was kind of a big
deal in the late 1990s when they do
Priya's they've done like extensive
archaeological digs on Roanoke Island
because a lot of people are fascinated
by this case they're trying to like find
evidence of where these people went and
stuff like that so they did an
excavation there and they found what
they thought at first was a gold ring
like a signet ring that had like a lion
kind of thing I don't he's like oh
that's like from the Kendall family like
the Kendall could have arms and that was
one of the families that came here with
you know the settle
yeah and so they made a big deal about
it but then later on when they did kind
of like chemical analysis and stuff like
that they found out the ring was not
gold that it was brass yeah and that
what was on it yeah it was a lion thing
but it's like it probably came from
maybe like a hundred hundred fifty years
later so it was probably just kind of
like traded with the Native Americans
and so probably didn't have anything to
do with the Lost Colony because for they
got like super excited about it but you
know I don't think it had anything to do
with the Lost Colony you know or where
they went or anything like that it's an
enduring American mystery yeah and like
I said we have you know we have a lot of
American listeners but we also have like
a lot of British listeners we have a lot
of we have so many listeners yeah stuff
like that so I always I don't know how
like commonly this mysteries no but it's
a very very from our generation we knew
about it yeah I don't know if the
younger generations know too much about
Roanoke Island and about the fact that
people used to trip out about what
happened to them yeah where'd they go
yeah well I have to say that like I
watched their psyche a funny you know
BuzzFeed unsolved yeah this is this -
funny guys they may be paranormal but
they also do like sure crime kind of
[ __ ] - and their um I don't know how old
they're but they're probably like
younger than we are I think they're
going their 20s or 30s and the one guy
on there said that he had learned about
it in grade school so they're still
teaching it I guess I mean it's like
it's kind of a big deal because like I
said had they known what happened to
them that would have been the oldest
colony in what became the United States
part of it I think might be the 20th
century thinking in the 1900s white
people usually worried whether or not
non-white people could integrate into a
white dominated society so that's how
they looked at the Roanoke problem they
do that that's a good point they didn't
realize that it could be back together
then it was a white population
integrating into a non-white society
they'd never thought of that okay and
that's what happened that's a really
interesting yeah because I don't really
think until fairly recently because I
remember learning about this in school
and everybody I mean like mystified
about what
yeah like it's almost like it never
occurred to them well yeah that like
white people like integrate with exactly
those ideas had a stew weasel I grew up
in Brazil yeah I never really had that I
was a minority there as a white guy and
to me Brazilians are just people yeah
yeah I mean so that's what happened
today she's funny I never really thought
of it from that perspective might be
right about that and in the nineteen and
the a why it took so long for people to
come to yeah in the eighteen hundreds
they called in the eighteen hours they
called that going engine side with them
and and you hear that to a lot of the
mindset of today about you know what
happened with the Indian genocide is
actually based in a lot of these
nineteen hundred's concepts of racism
that didn't exist in the 1500s British
people weren't racist in the 1500s they
just got here and they saw some other
people and they wrote back about how
good-looking they were you're projecting
a 1900s and a nineteen of 21st and 20th
century mentality back on other people
that lived in the 1500s and like I say
worse racist it was always well and it
was a look I think it was a lot more
complex than people kind of have than
people perceive it as too because like I
said even when the first settlers came
to Roanoke like they encountered natives
here that were friendly to them and
natives that were not friendly to them
but just depended on what tribe they
came from like how they interacted when
you start getting into the 16th and
1700s like in the islands you know where
that where all the Pirates were at all
yes shipping you know what am I thinking
of like in in Puerto Rico what
everything it's nothing but it's just a
story of race-mixing really on those
ships they had people of different races
and women of different races and it
didn't matter and who you were married
to as long as you were married to
somebody you know I mean because they
were kind of freed from Europe and
everyone was so lucky it's kind of far
away yeah it was it was almost not like
people that almost wanted to get back
whattcha whattcha that were sent away
from exactly who said this was this was
a scene
there's a bunch of wild asked
[ __ ] and they were freely
breeding with each other upon upon a
natural basis it's just if you were
good-looking you're gonna get some they
really didn't care too much
it's just how a person treats you like I
said you're just [ __ ] or no no yeah
yes pretty much myself I don't I don't
really understand it I only understand
the power of ass should we cook this
close this [ __ ] out
alright are we gonna talk but I have a
nice ask that right Oh fantastic thank
you big old titties we probably
shouldn't call near Roanoke this summit
up you know I was white people
integrating mostly I think they
integrated they like I said maybe a
couple of them died from other things I
don't think they were white I don't
think these white than that I like that
they never found all their bodies if
anything the leadership of the Roanoke
colony tried to [ __ ] run to Croatoan
Island there was they were talking maybe
between 5 and 10 people they didn't make
it the rest of them Pro that integrated
just their descendants became India's
yeah I think they just kind of dispersed
it yeah you think they got married yeah
like people from like I think people
that are arguing against that are like
oh when Jamestown was established which
was only like 20 years later yeah
they're like why didn't any of them
contact us they were married they were
just like oh [ __ ] that [ __ ] that we're
living good with the tribes and we're
married ground I got kids what would
they do 20 years later right they're
gonna show back up to the new colonies
this Oh a I've been gone home by the way
here's my wife yeah you know I mean and
here's are your children no it wouldn't
work that's what 20 years is a long time
I wouldn't work and I kind of feel like
they went out to live their own life yes
they probably just went often and then
when they heard about that like oh
that's nice yeah
that's not a work yes you know we're
doing our own [ __ ] over here they got
wife and kids I gotta go hunt Buffalo I
ain't worried about that right exactly I
think that's probably what happened they
just I think they just went wrong you
know that's went native I guess I'm
saying that with I run it yeah and then
in the 80s a car going into an engine
going engine yeah I think that's what
they did I don't think they got killed
on yeah like that there was anything and
like I said there's a lot of stupid [ __ ]
bow they got kidnapped by aliens elves
oh come on like oh my god really
down down and that's why I laughed about
like the BuzzFeed one you'll watch the
BuzzFeed unsolved about this because I
love that the one guy is kind of like
kind of open to quote-unquote paranormal
yeah they got kidnapped by all the other
guys like man [ __ ] you no aliens didn't
get a mascot you gotta get married
eventually you know I mean the power the
biological power of mating you know I'm
talking about this subacute came along
and you're gonna do what you're gonna do
you know course or you can get behind
you depend on one sec yeah well yeah if
you get behind one yeah why yeah it's
good we're getting to Joe hopefully you
enjoyed this 4th of July Independence
Day fireworks yeah it's like don't
please don't blow your fingers off or
anything like that don't don't drink and
fireworks anything else
don't drink and grill and yeah and
remember if you liked the show remember
to Like share subscribe on all your
social media share with all your friends
and if you would like to financially
support the show you can go to our
patreon page which is patreon.com slash
13 o'clock podcasts or you can go to our
blog which is 13 o'clock podcast at
wordpress.com and there's a link in the
sidebar to a PayPal in the sidebar up in
the sidebar well you can time donation
like Eric did thank you again Eric just
give you another shout out it's a gothic
yes also remember to check out our
latest movie review which was the dead
zone from 1983 very good Stephen King
adaptation if you haven't seen it you
should check it out and that'll do it
for episode 98 we'll see you next time
happy 4th of July
bye
[Music]
where's Rowena
[Music]
[Music]
but just Croatoan mean anyway
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]